et bonjour et bienvenue dans le studio
diagonale tv avec la star de
saint-quentin 2015 a star absolue
puisque c'est le champion de france en
titre
christian bauer bonjour question
champion de france toutes catégories
presque vingt ans vingt ans après un
premier titre alors 19 ans était en 96 à
auxerre à l'époque j'avais été le plus
cher qu'en france le 10 novembre
donc ça fait dix neuf de plus ça fait 19
de plus donc tous les 19 ans tu as
décidé de là je me suis fixé cinq
objectifs auraient bien alors il faut
quand même absolument rappeler au public
que tu es aussi cette année champion de
france rapide
oui donc ça c'était à nancy s'étaient
organisés par christophe philippe et
j'avais fait un beau tournoi j'avais
notamment battu laurent frayssinet a
nancy l'annoncé d'un retour à dire que
le goûter j'allais participer il entend
lui et donc ça a été très important ce
titre sans doute cette année parce que
sa tasse de sans doute donner confiance
à rapide et aujourd'hui tu as réussi
mais comme d'autres parties dans ce
tournoi presque retourné une situation
qui était un peu délicate voire même
très délicate et du a réussi à
l'emporter sur le fil dans une deux une
partie que ton adversaire tu dame
d'amiens a mis beaucoup de temps à
assimiler ont il est resté longtemps à
sa table à se demander ce qui s'était
passé
oui bon ce qui se comprend parce que mon
autant la première partie avait été très
chaotique
je ne sais même pas quelle était
l'évaluation qui a dû aussi beaucoup
autant la deuxième
bon après les 15 premiers coups j'ai
raté qu'il allait jouer qui avait les
projets 6 ch 5 et après c'était très
difficile pour moi est donc parti à ce
moment-là objectivement gt gt puis mais
bon on avait plus beaucoup de temps
chacun des étages de ta meilleure chance
parce que tu le laisses tu le laisse en
fait prendre purement au 6 mai tu peut
encore bouger beaucoup et il n'a pas
encore gagné quoi oui donc après il a le
choix il peut échanger les dames mais ce
combat il a qu'un qui ont de plus ou
alors jouer la suite de la partie où il
a trois pions mais il ya des
footballeurs opposée puis tout à coup je
suis actif et puis c'est à lui de parler
des menaces en tout cas c'est
fantastique à suivre se départagent et
et c'était beau de voir comment tu es
capable comme ça de de tenir des trucs
de sortir de la caisse de dédier tout
les liens et les sortir de l'eau au
final comme houdini et après bon c'est à
dire aussi qu'on était fatigués tous les
deux le tournoi est très éprouvant mais
on a joué le matin donc tigran a dû
défendre moi j'ai essayé de gagner
pendant longtemps une position qui était
avantageuse donc on a joué
faux lui quatre heures m a quasiment 5
matin mais partie extrêmement disputé
d'ailleurs
ces deux partis de tête était
extrêmement tendue et dont l'enjeu était
important
on a vu d'ailleurs la partie avec
sébastien bazin a analysé avec nous et
il a vraiment accroché ce qui n'était
pas évident parce que lui n'était pas
dans l'optique de gagner grand chose
non mais la boisson oui parce qu'on va
essayer de faire de son mieux et bon
assez vite il s'est retrouvé sous
pression au début il a pris pas mal de
temps parce que l'ouverture était allé
un peu exotique et s'est vite il a eu à
défendre ce qu'il a très bien fait en
fin de set est beau moi j'ai trouvé que
c'était extrêmement tendue ce tournoi
assez assez beau ça marc degraeve aussi
tu as fait un très bon tournoi et contre
qui il a aussi tu as gagné une partie
qui était quand même assez belle où
c'était difficile oui et à la fesse et à
retourner complètement le sens va
globalement je puis j'ai pris beaucoup
de risques dans quasiment toutes les
parties qui nourrissent quoi et bombe à
cette fois ça a payé
après c'est c'est beaucoup plus fatigant
aussi que de jouer très solide oui et
compte y avait que ce tournoi par
exemple comme tu vois etienne bacrot qui
qui fait beaucoup de nuls et puis qui se
remonte peu à la fin du concert à le
sentir remontée fort quand tu es ce que
tu avais les autres adversaires ou
simplement tu te concentres sur ton jeu
oui mais j'ai joué mon tournoi et puis
bon en espérant qu'ils tiennent vraiment
pas assez après c'est une question de
style mais il a joué peut-être trop
solide lui quand il avait les noirs
particulièrement donc sa stratégie n'est
pas forcément mauvaise mais ça implique
de
de faire un maximum de points entier
avec les deux langues et quand ils n'y
arrivent pas à ce moment là il faut
aller un peu à la pêche
et quand christian valat pêche des
histoires des truc du chapeau des la
peine des machins trucs c'est incroyable
alors peut-être une petite parenthèse
échec dans l'émission puis à pontault
demandera pour conclure tout simplement
comment tu vois la saison prochaine que
ce ont été grands rendez vous et on va
voir cette partie entre toi même et
tigran gharamian alors la partie là qui
s'est fait dans le tournoi long parce
que la partie était peut-être plus
intéressante est peut-être le moment
critique dit qu'il intéresse le plus
qu'est ce que tu veux voir ce que tu
peux les voir dans cette partie pour
être un moment précis alors le moment là
déroulé puis tu ne ris encore elle rit
là il a une position tout à fait correct
assez vite
la position était probablement enfin été
équilibrée et un moment critique c'est
quand il a décidé de jouer le groupe des
six des cinq rangs barça une sicilienne
donc tuer les blancs captant empêcher le
dessin les fous alors on a le téléphone
qui sonne à boiter souvenant qu'un petit
bruit mais c'est normal et ça fait
partie des missions c'est voulu c'est
parce que christian reçoit énormément de
sms et d'appels mais sur suite à son
titre forcément tous ses supporters
l'appel
sa famille ses amis voilà donc le coût
des cinq dont je parlais voilà cinq fois
c'est typique dans la cécilienne ça
libère le fawcett
ça empêche aussi que les blancs
fonds qui se libère un peu voilà que les
blancs met le verrou sur la case des
cinq d'effectivement jouant tour en d1
wintour ans des liens qu'auraient pu
venir et donc les noirs se libère ainsi
aussi d'une des pions arriérés en
déciderait après dans ce cas précis
c'est aussi quelque part là le début des
soucis pour les noirs ah c'est à dire
qu'ils auraient pu jouer quelque chose
comme tour c8 ou c5 dans ma vie tout
dames c'est cette préparer cette poussée
plus voilà plus précisément parce que
c'est un peu tout ça huîtres en
l'occurrence bon je te sers placer une
tour en d1 mais ensuite c'est pas si
clair comment je vais renforcer ma
position
oui alors qu'après des 5 le jeu devient
plus direct alors on regarde un peu ce
qui se passe alors voilà donc forcément
tu prends parce que des cas de menaces
voilà je prends qui va les prendre donc
maintenant je te reprendre aussi des
échanges et maintenant j'avais hésité
entre jouer avec tout de suite mais toi
d un naturel pour des émissions
messieurs ont une tour vis-à-vis de la
dame en plus voilà donc la cie les noirs
avaient le temps de jeu il faut prendre
b3 puis d'échanger les fourons avec vous
ces cinq réellement qu'il n'aurait pas
de problèmes mais ils n'ont pas le temps
et n'est ce pas le temps passer de quoi
ducloy ici c'est ça voilà et
et donc surtout promet 3 puis on prend
b3 2007 on peut regarder tu me proposes
on va regarder cette variante variante
vous prends plein de francs comprend
deux sets 6 7 % levée du cloud âge parce
que sinon il menace damas trois par
exemple voilà avec des idées de faux
proxis et puis ensuite foot est roi je
suis ici je rejoins entre la f4 ou alors
droit à agen pour regarder le foot par
exemple s4 ici oui donc c'est pas
forcément le plus prometteur mais c'est
une option
et sinon on voit le coup je pensais
jouer c'est héros h un accord est sur
flu c5 est sûre en c5 ici ici
probablement poussé pour garder le cap
heures de fou ya pas d histoire de fou
principe d'un match 3 qui attaquent le
pian lecavalier mais voilà il ya aussi
ça après est ce que ça donne lieu de la
nul après 1,6 g prend en chine d'un
match 3 tours f18 sais pas si claire
d'accord donc pousser un peu pour
menacer des choses voilà voilà donc la
foule des cats est pas possible à cause
du cloud âge qui se ferait pour prendre
des 4 as oui d'accord a oui mais ce
qu'évidemment il ya dan dan et ça c'est
pas bon et maintenant je vais continuer
soit par d'un match 3 soit 13,4 pour
ouvrir pour les deux fous est ici
clairement les blancs un potentiel de
leurs attaques
voilà deux fous contre le roi c'est ça
voilà entre le fou sur cette diagonale
l'un l'autre qui menacent de s'échanger
à 6 tout le temps ça que marcquois est
donc ici les noirs n'ont probablement
pas utiliser d'accord donc ça explique
que la suite de la partie donc ça
explique alors si on revient juste un
peu avant la is it aura d un don qui
joue faux h4 voilà il n'y a pas de radar
alors fois en 80 peu
un peu bizarre mais surfent aussi sur
jouer f4 d'accord et en cas de prison à
4 après j'aurai la casse des 80
cavaliers et à wil saluant la pression
en scène fait qu'ensuite le cavalier va
venir un attaquant fou et pièces vont
vite vers l envoi lavage et de toutes
les pièces qu'ils sont bien placés ouais
d'accord et donc fois le 4e meilleur
coût et la dame g4 force et parce que si
dommage 3 il faut aussi ce qui pose
problème comme on voit la dame est un
peu coincée alors comme des anges et 4
après tout aussi celle de coulisses et
un peu où elle veut exactement à quoi
c'est ce qui se passe ailleurs fo et 6
et la dame coulissant avec l'atr voilà
maintenant de nouveau je veux jouer f4 a
toujours un pour libérer le chou coin et
billets pour 17,7 kazan dé cap rouge et
c'est très important parce que c'est
pour l'instant mon cavalier ne fait pas
grand chose et puis faire soit espion
centrale finalement en la quittant même
embêtant parce qu'ils y pour l'instant
il contrôle bien le centre donc faux g5
il d'accord pour échanger un fou et
simplement tu prends voilà voilà prise
prises et là maintenant ton fameux est
gâté quand même
voilà donc on fait sauter le centre et
puis on est bien quoi on va avoir du
aérez c'est le rock un peu faible et
puis si on a trois pions contre devenue
elle aussi
alors c'est oui aux as le centre c'est
pas grand chose mais ça devient un peu
de l'activité délicat pour les pour les
noirs ce cabinet qui arrive en d4
j'avais dit qu'il va venir en d4 pose un
problème aux fous donc on continue
pris dans prends ta valise et 16 h
voilà donc maintenant aussi je prends la
dame et le cavalier il va avoir des
pions faible mais
il va ensuite joué autour des 8 et
vendues contre eux oui tu prends
comprendre cavale et prend appuie ses
pions sur isolé voila voila comme auteur
de huit arrivées au coup suivant je pas
facile non j'avais promis n'ont pas
profité de la structure donc là j'ai
joué les cavaliers des quatre noms voilà
toujours année mis des gants n'attend
que fou mais notre bécane rossini
j'arrive donc la prolonger l'aurait dû
échanger les dames plutôt que de me
laisser - échanger 5
d'accord il n'y a pas fait ça mais il a
joué tout desuite 17 et maintenant le
coût qu'il avait faits qui lui avait
échappé après de l'amsterdam puis on
prend donc tu as fait d'un point dame h
prend et maintenant à cinq qui est assez
très jeune alors tu détruis un peu ça le
plus calme et plus et il soit plus
stable
les plus stables et le son problème
c'est que sur le coup logique
b prend 1,5 jouer cavalier p 3 alors si
des prend 1,5
simplement des trois cavaliers bt la
part donc avec la libye 3 oui l'idée
section qui avait les prends je prends
le foot emprise ensuite il doit jouer et
qui avait laissé cinq et là par exemple
tout reprend et sur kyle et ses cinq
tours des 5 et ramasse tout autour en
outre point vous êtes aussi tourcoing
cette épreuve non plus format
si après tourcoing 7 bonds supérieurs
aux cavaliers j'ai une meilleure
structure de pions fou contre un
cavalier les pires ont doublé ici
doubler la wii c'est clairement
l'avantagé blanche est d'accord donc en
fait donc c'est pour ça que sur à 5 e
mais il s'est pas déplacé mais
probablement que c'est déjà délicat et
donc comme c'était de cette note
ça va pas ça ne va pas l'aider donc il
fait qu'avaya 4 aussi d'être titille un
peu les structures ici faire bouger tout
ça mais tranquille on est triste et bf3
peut-être le fouet du change est simple
le foot attaqué le pion j'essaie le pion
v6 est toujours en prix voilà donc pas
joué depuis trois ans et qu'elle est
cette fois c'est ça oui donc mon sac
quelques précisément par exemple enfin
le lait avec les cavs et dans des cas
que je pouvais et parfois même je peux
envisager de sacrifier la qualité en d1
si j'arrive enfin si j'arrivais avant le
pion c'est simple déjà mais il va
manquer un tempo d'accord donc on
enchaîne quand même fou c'est fou et 100
ch il joue avec le foot est attaqué il
attaque ses deux vols apparaît bien donc
cavalier pranger s'inquiète un peu fou
aussi et encore une fois le tour qui
attaque un full circle et n'auront pas
le temps de respirer coin ça ça va vite
qui alors ça fait peur autour des quatre
tours h4 wii donkey là il a jugé la
menace b3 dans l'es3 symbian il ya le
pion à vii qui attaque et est donc là
bas c'est vraiment très délicat à jouer
en tête note ah oui alors dengue hélas
le temps mais sûr je lui aussi
il fait ici souffrent ces deux encore
encore un appel encore y est on vraiment
pas toute la france avec christian ce
moment faux procès devant n'est vraiment
en direct de saint quentin juste après
le titre de christian tour c'est un
voilà tu attaques le fou quand même pas
perdre de temps ouais et toujours j'ai
envie de jouer et que b 3-1 et en plus
le câble et ne pouvaient pas aller en c3
et oui du coup sans l'aide des cases aux
cavaliers biya à prendre et si ce qui
arrive
il ya là ils avaient un choix délicat il
pouvait jouer tous les trois aussi au
lieu de 6 pour défendre également le le
pion f7 et oui sa défense là aussi ça
des bouffons celle de la pêche p3 mais
là il fallait calculer tour f 3,3
attaque le fou et oui enfin ça la
question
voilà donc silva en d5 je peux
éventuellement faire échec au hc suite
et maintenant b3 de haut niveau et et
latour protège le câble et bouger b6
tombe voilà qui est bon de nouveau
c'était compliqué parce que sur calais
c5 si je prends un imbécile peut prendre
b 3 à prendre un an pardon ici qu'à
blesser son cavalier ces singes apprend
il prend du cavalier palier sinon une
toilette emprise hélas le carlit emprise
et donc si ce fou saute il semblerait
qu'ils perdent une pièce voilà donc pour
mon tour d un à tour des attaques fou
est là
apparemment il veut du mal du protégé et
oui parce que s'il fait pas rien de
tours d'éviter d'en haut de la tour et
on récupère le tiens à dire mon cavalier
g5 aussi à huy alors on fait pour ça
donc par exemple s'il fait tour celle là
par exemple en des huit caisses qui
dominait en plus viennent d'un fils à
terre alors peut-être que je vais être
déjà quand même et maintenant je passe
sur tourbe et huit par jour et au moins
/ - comprend 1 6 1 6 la bahia qui avait
laissé cinq ans et ouais c'est compliqué
c'est nelly peur du ridicule et ses 28
note voilà c'est ça qui compte ici c'est
diaz et de notes et tout ça est très bon
complète donc j'ai choisi fuji 6 voilà
voilà
voici variante me choisissent ou g6
carrière en moins compliqué mais après
b3 qui avait laissé cinq 5 pions tant
qu' on prend 1,6 quand même si on prend
2,6 par rapport aux moyens et la carie
prend b3 met donc il ya plus de choses
sur le sol en tout cas oui mais
maintenant après tout c'est cette il ya
quand même des grosses difficultés parce
que j'attaque le pion f7 je me laisse
bessette
une fois deux fois trois fois défendu
que deux fois et donc là il a pas le
choix c'était ce qu'il faut filer active
de son champion c'est ça oui enfin
probablement qu objectivement c'est déjà
trop tard
/
sur cavaliers des quatre au lieu de deux
à cinq qu'il a joué ce jour et pourrait
m'en fous ces quatre pour attaquer
encore ce qu'ils ont à fait d'accord et
de nouveau j'ai toujours cette idée de
de behcet et 7 la tour doit venir en
d'éviter il a simplement fait preuve
ainsi ces gymnastes tour s'est vite il
faut prendre ainsi si c'est fini
cependant ses pions que c'est monstrueux
c'est quoi c'est en fait la grosse
différence c'est que ceux qui ont eu
beaucoup plus avancé que celui-là et que
les noirs la censure vraiment
complètement dévissé par l'avancée du
pion à d'assurer si si si par exemple je
crois que le bced soutien d'un fils y
aura pas de match il est presque normal
parce qu'il va y avoir mais justement si
je commence par france est à la fois de
plus efficace ton pays sur des vies et
maintenant tous rêvent quatre voies la
tour eiffe quatre attaques lecavalier et
les menaces échec et mat régime en voie
de prendre le cavalier sans doute faut
prendre le câble et là je prends la tour
à huy à ses parts dès maintenant pour
celui aiaiai tour s'est vite et c'est
assez la classique on prend et adam et
puis prochaine coup ces dames 1
voilà pour prendre pour prendre tour est
donc bon il va jouer à 5 mais après
c'était
cette orbite et sept tours avait huit
maintenant sous ces quatre là même idée
voilà je tacle cavaliers en plus et le
fouet le pion toujours donc la cad
qu'elle a les crocs et auxerre car
l'épreuve cet échec il donne le vous
tous rêvent set et après tourcoing et
sète sous prend à vii junas tour 6 buts
échelle en menace pour s'éviter chez les
dames on ans qui joue le rôle courage 7
est maintenant pour ces trois sa menace
maths à et sa menace de simplifier par
fo prend b3 échec et mat jamais si beau
ça leroy regarder le roi est
complètement coincés ici par le fou et
le pion g7 donc en fait y'a pas de
couloir oui je suis obligé de vous est
ici
g6 par exemple 6 ou g6 alors g6 et là
j'aurai le feu prend b3 la trempe chine
puis on prend pour preuve les trois pour
prendre et c'est touré vice et il ya de
plus en plus compromis si ces morts
magnifique il abandonne en fait
ici quand après auxerre après toi 7,3
après tour ces trois courses et trois
superbes donc forcément finir oui mais
après c'était la deuxième ronde après il
va quand même est vite revenu d'allegri
la suivante oui quand tu resteras tescou
une partie aussi qui était qu'il est bas
pendant longtemps et il a quand même
gagné cinq parties donc après cette
défaite
il a fait un retour note sylvie deux
fois c'est le seul joueur à être venus
deux fois sauf dans les visions d'accord
voilà
et nous on est très content de t'avoir
comme une con champions parce que si tu
avais pas été champions ce soir on
n'aurait pas pu avoir
parce que tu serais parti évitez et la
wii c'est normal mais là c'est quand
même un très beau champion chanter
france rapide triple champion de france
maintenant auteur d'un fameux livre sur
la défense unidor voiliers qui date un
peu
quidam mais qui est très connue parce
que quantité de joueurs on parle de ce
livre et quantité de joueurs se sont mis
à jouer à philidor qui maintenant
devient un vrai problème quand on joue
des mots ça va ça m'agace que je suis à
une autre un peu marre c'était sa
première oui papa avait fait donc le sag
a pas porté chance mais tu joues plus
lente arrêté peut-être je range ou
étonnant mais c'est pas mon ouverture
principal
alors pour finir rapidement le christian
parce que je sais que tu as donc tu es
très attendu et tu dois les manger cette
saison qui s'annonce c'est quoi le grand
rendez-vous pour toi alors je faire
plusieurs championnats par équipes au
tournoi individuel moi je veux jouer au
cap d'agde
j'aime beaucoup prendre là en plus c'est
très pratique
c'est à côté de montpellier et et puis
pour le moins zurich à noël et puis
avant l'open de 29 ans on l'a encore
chargé et puis forcément nationale 2016
qui va bien sûr arriver bravo christian
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi sur
cinquantaine 2004 c'était la dernière
émission avec donc le champion absolu du
jeu d'échecs en france cette année c'est
le grand maître christian bauer 3e titre
au revoir